[Musique]
on connaît tous la longue histoire de la
famille molson à montréal et dans tout
le pays en 2005 molson et la brasserie
américaine qu elles ont fusionné leurs
activités
aujourd'hui le cinquième plus grand
producteur de bière du monde est en
train de devenir une entreprise de
boissons végétales au cannabis eau
pétillante alcoolisées whisky café avec
nous ce soir frédéric lambert ce pdg de
monceau corse canada bonsoir
on connaît mons une course pour la bière
mais quand je décris toutes ces
nouvelles boissons j'ai le goût de vous
demander quelle est la part qu'occupent
la bière maintenant dans vos activités
par rapport aux autres produits
et aujourd'hui il est clair que la bière
occupants pour une part la plupart de
notre volume de nos revenus proviennent
de la vielle
ça me fait que deux ans qu'ont annoncé
qu'on changerait notre nom notre
entreprise
de l'entreprise brassicole qu'on a été
depuis deux cent trente cinq ans
l'entreprise de boissons on a l'ambition
de devenir et tout ça c'est un processus
donc aujourd'hui comme je m'étais de nos
revenus proviennent de la bière mais il
est clair que c'est plus qu'un
changement nous on explore d'autres
segments s'est lancé dans certains
segments
et les revenus qui proviennent des
catégories autre que la bière augmente
tous les jours alors par exemple on a
sept cette entité qui s'appelle tracé
bidi us et qui est une entreprise créée
par molson coors et exo et là on
annonçait justement aujourd'hui où cette
semaine que les boissons à base de
cannabis seront disponibles dans 17
états américains alors parlons des
boissons au cannabis quelle est
l'importance de ce type de boisson dans
l'avenir de molson coors je pense que ce
qu'on a vu pour nous cet instinct
segment qu'on a qu'on a explosé aussitôt
que
que le cannabis est venue a été légalisé
six au canada fin 2018 le cannabis au
niveau récréatif je dirais est très vite
devenu une catégorie de plusieurs
milliards de dollars ici au canada il
est vrai que la proportion des boissons
infusé au cannabis aujourd'hui est
encore relativement faible
donc je pense que ça vous donne la
réponse par rapport à l'importance dans
notre portefeuille aujourd'hui mais
soyons clairs aussi ces produits ont été
lancés en plein milieu d'une meute d'une
pandémie pour mettre un chiffre sur
l'importance de cette catégorie là je
pense qu'il est trop tôt dans le
développement de la catégorie pour
pouvoir s'exprimer de façon très précise
à ce niveau là annoncé en mai dernier
d'un investissement de 100 millions de
dollars au canada pour kate de rue pelée
votre capacité de production d'eau
pétillante alcoolisées vous venez de
conclure une entente avec coca cola pour
distribuer sa au canada vous venez de
lancer du whisky aussi aux états unis et
là je regardais votre chiffre d'affaires
dans les dernières années ça décline
lentement mais ça décline quand même
est-ce que ce toutes ces nouvelles
boissons ont pour objectif d'aller
chercher une manque à gagner que vous
avez présentement dans votre chiffre
d'affaires
tous ses segments que nous explorerons
rendre l'âme hier ont effectivement
l'ambition d'augmenter nos revenus à
terme donc nous cherchons aussi bien les
pôles de croissance au sein de la vierge
je pense que c'est important de le
répéter et d'insister là dessus parce
que à la base nous restons une
entreprise brassicole et nous
continuerons à chercher les pôles de
croissance qui existe au sein de la
catégorie de la bière mais clairement
une catégorie comme les eaux pétillantes
alcoolisées on a vu un potentiel au
niveau des consommateurs on a vu un
intérêt au niveau de nos clients et nous
l'ont dit les jeunes consommateurs
surtout
nous au niveau de produits alcoolisés on
parle toujours des consommateurs adultes
jeudi radio mais quand même les plus
jeunes des adultes disons ces nouveaux
consommateurs qui ne cherche pas
nécessairement les biens traditionnel
je pense que ce qu'on a remarqué dans
leur recherche c'est que beaucoup de
consommateurs adultes en fait presque 50
% des consommateurs adultes cherchent
des alternatives cherche des nouveautés
donc la réponse à votre question suffit
lyon c'est qu'elles ne sont pas
seulement de jeunes consommateurs le
profil des consommateurs des eaux
pétillantes alcoolisées est en fait très
très large au niveau du du québec et du
canada est-ce que la stratégie de molson
coors est remise en question par les
investisseurs votre action est passé de
60 61 dollars en joie à 46 dollars
aujourd'hui comment vous l'expliquez
nous avons lancé en 2019 que nous avions
l'ambition de devenir une entreprise de
boissons nous avons annoncé à ce moment
là un plan de revitalisation de
l'entreprise je pense qu'il faut il faut
quand même être un contexte que une
transformation de cette envergure ça
prend du temps et quand je prends
l'exemple du canada par exemple on a
fait on est en train de passer à travers
une transformation non seulement nos
portefeuilles de marques mais aussi de
notre chaîne d'approvisionnement je vous
rappelle qu on a commencé à 5 ans à
construire une nouvelle brasserie en
colombie britannique
on achève aujourd'hui la construction
est une transition vers une nouvelle
brasserie à l'investissement d'un demi
milliard de dollar à longueuil tout ça
ça fait partie d'une transformation qui
prend du temps notre stratégie est très
claire on y croit on a été quelque peu
retardé je dirais par par le contexte
externe de la pandémie mais ça n'empêche
pas que nous restons focalisés sur cette
stratégie à laquelle nous croyons durant
la pandémie la photo d'une dame de 93
ans qui tenait une canette de bière
coors light à la mère disait jib haining
berger besoin de plus de bière saint-yvi
plus de 5 millions de fois partout dans
le monde véritable coup marketing pour
votre entreprise vous êtes en contact
avec elle vous leviez renvoyé de la
bière
nous en voulez de la vielle madame
s'appelle olive si je me souviens bien
et en fait à la base cette ça a commencé
avec une idée toute simple on avait on
avait remarqué
son affiche qu'elle avait posté à sa
fenêtre on s'était dit souvenons nous à
ce moment là c'était quand même des
temps très très dur et notre ambition à
ce moment là c'était de mettre un
sourire
parmi parmi les gens et c'est cette
amérique
il ya des millions de personnes qui
ont vu cette à cette action je pense que
ça fait partie des actions marketing
qu'on appelle actions marketing après
les faits mais qui partent une idée
toute simple c'est toujours agréable
pour une entreprise quand ce genre de
choses à ce produit monsieur l'admettait
remercie et d'avoir été avec nous merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit